[MUSIC]
This is not a normal year, we've been
looking at each other on screen and
occasionally from a distance
of six feet or more.
As you know, Stanford is a special place,
the beauty of the campus,
the ability to learn
from brilliant faculty,
the culture of collaboration and
optimism, and most of all the people.
During your time at the GSB you've gone
from being a set of individuals to being
a class that's held together by bonds that
even social distancing cannot diminish.
The pandemic is shown how much
the world needs leaders for
society, who make decisions
based on data and reason,
who act boldly to demonstrate
compassion and inspire others.
You are those leaders, we are counting
on you to bring your ideas,
your experience, and your passion to
whatever you do and wherever you go.
[MUSIC]
>> Congratulations to the Stanford
Graduate School of Business Class of 2020.
I am so proud of all of you,
what you have accomplished is remarkable.
You have put yourselves on a journey
towards making a big impact in the world.
Simply put, you are the absolute
best of our future leaders.
Now, I know this is not exactly
the graduation you were all expecting.
At the same time, today's adversity
makes your class a truly historical.
And for now, congratulations on
your incredible achievement and
welcome to the GSB alumni family.
[MUSIC]